la primera ley de Newton nos dice que un
objeto en reposo va a permanecer en
reposo y que un objeto con velocidad
constante va a permanecer con su
velocidad constante hasta que se vea
afectada por algún tipo de fuerza neta y
de hecho pueden englobar esta ley
diciendo que un
objeto con velocidad constante podemos
decir que esta velocidad constante puede
ser igual a cero en caso de los objetos
en
reposo velocidad constante
va a permanecer con esa velocidad
constante hasta que llegue una fuerza
neta externa y lo afecte y esto nos
lleva a una pregunta obvia cómo es que
una fuerza neta puede afectar la
velocidad constante o cómo es que afecta
el estado de un objeto y esto nos lo
responde la segunda ley de
Newton La Segunda ley de
Newton del movimiento Segunda
ley del mov
nos
dice bueno Nos da una fórmula que es de
las más famosas que hay
Es que la
fuerza va a ser
igual a la
masa
multiplicada por la
ación lo que nos dice esto es que si
aplicamos una fuerza esta va a afectar
la velocidad constante Pero cómo Ah
Bueno antes de pasar a esto vamos a
aclarar que la aceleración es un vector
y que la
fuerza también es un
vector Entonces vamos a imaginar que
tenemos un
ladrillo y que pues está flotando en el
espacio si yo yo aplico una fuerza
neta
aquí y por qué me refiero o por qué digo
fuerza neta porque eh puedo yo aplicar
varias fuerzas una fuerza de este lado y
otra fuerza igual de este otro lado de
manera que se balanceen y eh No nos
afecten la velocidad constante de este
objeto en cambio una fuerza neta
aplicado de un solo lado o en una parte
o en un lado de este objeto sí nos va a
modificar su
comportamiento entonces
Eh bueno Yo estoy aplicando una fuerza
neta en uno de los lados del objeto y
esto me va a implicar que yo voy a tener
una
aceleración en en la misma dirección que
fue aplicada la
fuerza y la segunda ley nos dice que
esta aceleración va a ser proporcional a
la masa de este objeto Entonces nos
referimos esta M es
masa y aquí voy a hacer un video este
donde vamos a dedicarnos a explicar que
la masa es algo completamente diferente
al peso la masa es una medida de Cuánta
materia o de Cuánta materia está
compuesto algo un objeto y el peso es la
medida de cuánto de esa materia está
siendo jalado por la fuerza de gravedad
Así que el peso es una fuerza y bueno Y
es muy bueno que esta fórmula pues sea
así bastante sencilla y también vamos a
ver que la unidad de fuerza se llama
apropiadamente Newton vamos a ver un
ejemplo vamos a imaginar que tenemos una
fuerza de 10 New o lo podemos expresar
como 10
kg por Met sobre segundo cuadrado que
vienen siendo pues las mismas unidades
kilogramo viene siendo la unidad de masa
la aceleración tiene las unidades de
metro sobre segundo al cuadrado y esto
es lo mismo que Newton y eh vamos a
hacer que esta fuerza esté
actuando sobre una masa de 2
kg y lo que yo quiero saber es cuál va a
ser la
aceleración entonces pues ponemos estos
valores de acuerdo a esta fórmula
tenemos que 10 kg por Met sobre segundo
cuadrado va a ser igual a mi masa de 2
kg y eh va a estar multiplicada por la
aceleración para saber cuál es la
aceleración pues divido ambos
lados lo divido entre 2
kg igual de este lado 2
kg Aquí estos 2 kg se van a anular con
estos dos aquí las unidades kg se van a
anular 10 / 2 me va a quedar que 5 m
sobre segundo cuadrado porque los
unidades de los kilogramos aquí se han
anulado va a ser igual a mi aceleración
mi aceleración va a ser igual a 5 m por
segundo cuadrado
entonces eh vamos a ver Ah tenemos que
aclarar como la fuerza y la aceleración
son vectores en este video vamos a tomar
la convención de que las cantidades
positivas van a ir a la derecha y las
negativas a la izquierda entonces estas
son positivas esta fuerza es positiva
quiere decir que va a la derecha y aquí
la aceleración el resultado de la
aceleración fue una cantidad positiva
por lo que también la aceleración va a
ir hacia la derecha Qué pasa si yo
duplico la fuerza Si en lugar de 10 newt
digo que mi
fuerza va a ser
igual a 20 kg por Met sobre segundo al
cuadrado pues hago lo mismo la masa se
mantiene
igual entonces
eh voy a
tener 20 kg m sobre segundo cuadrado es
igual
a mis 2 kg y de hecho aquí estoy
confundiendo los colores Bueno vamos a
poner la aceleración con este color lo
mismo divido todo entre 2
kg sí 2 kg 2
kg y me va a quedar 2 20 / 2 es igual a
10 m por segundo al cuadrado va a ser
igual a mi
aceleración y vimos que bueno si
duplicamos la fuerza la aceleración
también se duplica qué va a pasar si yo
voy a si yo duplico la masa en lugar de
que sean 2 kg que la masa sean de 4 kg
en este último caso teníamos
que
eh
nuestra masa perón Nuestra fuerza de 20
kg por Met sobre segundo cuadrado Ahora
va a ser igual a mi masa que es el doble
mi masa va a ser de 4
kg la aceleración es lo que quiero saber
divido todo entre
4 igual de este lado esto se anula 20 /
4 5 m por segundo cuadrado va a ser
igual a mi
aceleración
Entonces si la masa es más grande
o la masa es el doble la aceleración va
a disminuir a la
mitad eso Es lógico Porque mientras más
grande sea la masa o más más masivo sea
un objeto va a requerir más fuerza para
acelerarlo o para
mover